حسنًا، لقد أتيت إلى وسط
العاصمة الروسية لمحاولة
التعرف على ما تشعر به هذه المدينة في
أعقاب محاولة
الانتفاضة العسكرية في عطلة نهاية الأسبوع، وأخبرك أن الأمر
يبدو مريحًا للغاية هنا، يمكنك أن ترى أن هناك
الكثير من الروس، الكثير من
السياح، آه الموجودين هنا يلتقطون
صورًا لهذه المواقع الشهيرة،
كنت أحاول الدخول إلى الميدان الأحمر
الموجود هنا بالفعل، ولكن
يمكنك أن ترى أن هناك حواجز في الأعلى، وفي
الواقع كانت هذه الحواجز موجودة منذ  في عطلة
نهاية الأسبوع عندما حدثت تلك الانتفاضة العسكرية،
يمكنك فقط رؤية
قباب سانت باسيل هناك على أي حال
للعودة إلى الناس، وأعتقد أنها ستكون
فرصة عظيمة للتحدث مع
بعض الروس حول مدى شعورهم بالأمان
الآن في أعقاب ذلك  من تلك
الانتفاضة مثل نيكولاي البالغ من العمر 86 عامًا
غير منزعج، أخبرني بأحداث الأيام الأخيرة أن
روسيا هي شعبها، كما يقول وليس بعض
التباهي الفردي وبغض النظر
عما يفعلونه، كانت روسيا
وستظل قوية
ولكن هل سيفعل زعيمها فلاديمير
أغلق بوتين خلف بوابات الكرملين هذه،
شكرًا لك يا
رب،
لا يريد الكثير من الناس التحدث معي
عن مكيف بوتين،
ولكن أولئك الذين يرفضون
الاقتراح الذي قدمه الرئيس
بايدن مؤخرًا بأن بوتين قد أضعفته
الثورة في روسيا،
أعتقد أنك ستكون موجودًا.  لفترة طويلة،
كانت سيسيليا جميع موارد البلاد
في يديه ولم تكن هناك
معارضة حقيقية ولن تكون هناك في أي وقت قريب، كما
يقول، لكنه الآن في المنفى، ويبدو أن
زعيم فاغنر الذي نظم وأجهض
التمرد لعبة عادلة في
الواقع، أنت تتحدث  الإنجليزية، حسنًا، رائع، دعني
أسألك ما رأيك في
يفغيني براغ، هل تحبه أم لا، لا، لا
تحبه، لا نحبه، لماذا
لا أعرف، لكنه ليس جيدًا،
إنه أمر مفهوم جدًا  أفترض أنك على علم
بما حدث خلال
الأيام القليلة الماضية،
فالناس لا يريدون حقًا التحدث
إلينا، وأنت تعرف الكثير أمام الكاميرا
لأنه على الرغم مما سيقوله معظمهم
لنا حول أن كل شيء على ما يرام
هنا، أعتقد ذلك  بصدق هناك شعور
بالتخوف بشأن ما قد تحمله
الأسابيع والأشهر المقبلة في هذا البلد لماثيو
تشانس سي إن إن في وسط
العاصمة الروسية موسكو
الأجنبية